[hinges creaking]
- I WAS WONDERING WHEN
I WOULD COME IN HERE TO FIND YOU
SITTING IN THAT CHAIR.
- IT WASN'T EASY
TRACKING YOU DOWN, DECKER.
- WASN'T SUPPOSED TO BE.
- I KNOW YOU'VE RETIRED,
BUT--
- THAT'S ALL BEHIND ME NOW,
GENERAL.
I'M NOT THE MAN YOU KNEW
DURING THE COLD WAR.
- I UNDERSTAND.
WE'RE NOW FACING A THREAT UNLIKE
ANY WE'VE EVER FACED BEFORE.
A MAN WITH YOUR EXPERTISE--
- I MADE A VOW.
NEVER TO KILL
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING.
SORRY, GENERAL, GONNA
HAVE TO FIND SOMEONE ELSE.
- OH...
NO, WE WEREN'T
THINKING YOU'D DO IT.
WE WERE--[clears throat]
JUST HOPING YOU COULD
RECOMMEND SOMEONE
FOR THE JOB.
- I GUESS I COULD
COME OUT OF RETIREMENT.
- NO. NO NEED.
JUST A RECOMMENDATION WILL DO.
- ALL RIGHT. I'LL DO IT.
- YOU KNOW, YOU'RE JUST
NOT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
- YOU SLY SON OF A BITCH.
YOU ALWAYS KNEW
HOW TO PUSH MY BUTTONS.
I'M IN.
- NOT YOU, DECKER.
- I'M SHARP AS I EVER WAS.
- [sighs]
- EVEN FASTER TOO.
GRAB MY HAND.
NOPE. WAIT TILL
I COUNT TO THREE FIRST.
- REALLY?
- ONE.
TWO.
THREE.
OKAY.
I WANT YOU TO TRY
AND SLAP ME IN THE FACE.
UNH! WASN'T READY FOR THAT.
TRY AGAIN.
UNH! OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
- NOW WHAT?
- DIDN'T HAVE MY ADRENALINE UP.
'CAUSE THIS IS NOT AN ACTUAL
HIGH-STAKES SITUATION.
ALL RIGHT.
DRAW YOUR WEAPON.
AND...DISARMED.
[gun hammer clicks]
YOU'RE GETTING PRETTY QUICK
AND DISARMED--OKAY.
I DON'T NEED
TO TAKE YOUR WEAPON.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHOOT ME.
- I AM NOT
GOING TO SHOOT YOU.
- WING ME IN THE SHOULDER.
- THIS IS RIDICULOUS!
- TRY, GENERAL.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
- [sighs]
- DEFLECTED--OOOWW!
- OKAY. I MADE
A MISTAKE COMING HERE.
- WING ME IN THE OTHER SHOULDER.
- I'D RATHER NOT.
- I INSIST.
DEFLECTED--AAAHH!
THAT WAS BECAUSE MY OTHER ARM
WAS ALREADY INJURED.
- OKAY. I'M LEAVING.
- [grunting] ALL RIGHT.
ALL OR NOTHING. GUT SHOT.
- NO!
- GUT SHOT! COME ON!
IF YOU CAN SHOOT ME IN THE GUT,
I'LL CONCEDE.
- DECKER, YOU HAVE
TWO WOUNDED ARMS.
- GUT SHOT! GO!
- GOT IT.
[groans]
- YOU--YOU CAUGHT THE BULLET?
- OH, YEAH.
[groans]
- SO YOU'RE TELLING ME
THAT THE BULLET
IS IN BETWEEN
YOUR HANDS RIGHT NOW.
- THAT'S WHAT
I'M TELLING YOU.
- [sighs]
[birds chirping]
- IS THAT ALL YOU GOT?
COME ON.
HEAD SHOT.
I'M READY.
ONE SEC THOUGH.
[gunshot]